this is GM Daniel nerdinski we have a
classic matchup for you Jana pamushi
with the white pieces and Carlson with
the black pieces at the 2022 fide World
splits championship and Magnus Carlson
with one E4 E5 he's played the French a
whole lot in the world Blitz but in this
particular game he does not mind a draw
he plays the Berlin nepo says I don't
want the Berlin end game I want an ante
Berlin and we have a very very popular
line as nepo trades his Bishop for black
snide on C6 damaging Black's Queen Side
Pawn structure but in return yielding
the bishop pair this type of structure
has been so well studied over the last
couple of decades both of these players
have had this exact position against
each other multiple times as Carlson
Twirls the bishop that he has just
recaptured and he slides his own Dark
Sword Bishop back to D6 in order to lend
additional support to that very
important Pawn in the center janapanishi
Castle's King side and black actually
has a major Choice here there's a fork
in the road black can move the queen out
from d8 as Vladimir kramnik was known to
do in the end of his career and Castle
Queen side he won some nice games but
Magnus Carlson he likes to play more
positionally he can of course also
Castle to the same side he can castle
kingside and then the battle frequently
shifts over to the center and the queen
side let's see what the world champion
decides he's taking his time he clearly
indicates that he takes this decision
very seriously will he play Queen E7 or
queen D7 or will he continue uh to
follow white by castling King side
Carlson has taken 30 seconds now and as
he is want to do janapanushi has handled
the opening very very quickly another
idea that black has to be very careful
about is the prospect of the d-pawn
moving up to D4 notice that Black's
Bishop on D6 and Knight on F6 are
unforkable squares so after D4 e takes
D4 white could slide the pawn up to E5
and Fork two of Black's minor pieces so
that is a tactic black has to be very
careful about and speaking of which
Carlson decides to push his Pawn up to
C5 and establish the clamp on the D4
square that pawn now cannot move up to
D4 and the pawn on C5 can be supported
with BC six I think it's safe to say
that Carlson is not going to Castle
Queen side he moves his Queen from d8 to
C8 he's going to Castle kingside and
he's going to try to keep control as
much control as possible over the center
and contain the possibility of white
pushing the pawn up to D4 in the
meantime janapanishi continues to play
quickly as he slid his Knight up to A5
putting pressure on B7 and followed It
Up by playing B3 this was the real
reason he moved the Knight away from B3
he wants the square for the pawn and
then he wants the B2 Square for his dark
squared Bishop to put pressure on
Carlson's E5 Pawn first he slides his
Knight back from A5 to C4 and the battle
is revolving around that E5 Pawn nepo
jumps to the other side with his other
Knight Knight to G5 forcing a trade of
Black's Bishop for the Knight on C4
and now we have a very interesting Pawn
structure in the center both sides have
a lot of damage on the queen side
doubled C pawns for both players but it
doesn't seem like neither side has
really any significant weaknesses in the
center of the C5 pawn and the E5 Pawn
they're both very well protected by
Black's Bishop on D6 that's not the
nicest looking Bishop it's not going to
win any beauty contests but it's it's
doing the heavy lifting it's doing yo
man's work defending C5 and E5 I think
Magnus has succeeded in equalizing but
not equalizing on the clock he keeps
looking off to the side he seems a
little bit concerned I don't know about
what maybe he's thinking about his
tournament situation but he's down to
right around a minute on the clock and
we're barely out of the opening but here
goes the world champion F6 F5 what a
committal move as he rips open the king
side and perhaps even the center and
nepo says okay I'm taking on F5 give me
that E4 Square the white could try to
maneuver his knight from F3 to E4
instead an upper brings his Queen up to
E2 and perhaps the queen could sink its
teeth onto E4 what was the idea of
opening up the file well it was to
activate Black's rook and to put
pressure on the Knight on F3 and then
Carlson could slide his knight from D7
to F6 and perhaps later on prepare a
pawn breakthrough in the center with E5
E4 but if he plays Knight F6 then nepo
could deploy his Bishop to B2 and then
perhaps his Rook could come to E1 and
Carlson could suddenly have a hard time
defending the E5 pawn and so he decides
to keep his Knight on D7 instead he
makes some improvements on the queen
side he plays the move B6 and maybe he
wants to bring his Queen out to B7 a fee
and kettle of the queen not something
you say every day and then move the
other Rook from A8 over to E8 or to f8
but whatever he wants he needs to decide
it fast Carlson down to 30 seconds God
he is not playing quickly here nepo
still with over two minutes on his clock
that is very very typical of course Yana
palmushi is known for playing very
quickly even in Blitz at both Rooks
coming to the center rookie one and now
rookie eight by Carlson the E5 Pawn is
still pretty well protected in fact all
of Black's pieces it's accept his Queen
are currently protecting the E5 pawn and
we mentioned this maneuver a little bit
earlier the Knight swings from F3 to D2
and now it can go forward to E4 that is
a very nice Central Square where the
Knight is looking at both sides of the
board and it seems to me that nepo has
won the Early Middle game struggle
White's position looks absolutely great
all of the pieces are breathing They're
all playing the Knight on e4 is
phenomenal but for the time being well
the world champion is still very very
solid the Knight on e4 looks pretty but
what exactly is it going to attack
that's the question how is nepo going to
create actual
actual chances against Black's King side
and against black center and Carlson
he continues to improve his own position
he moves his Knight away from D7 and
back to f8 and clearly the Knight is
heading for E6 and then perhaps either
to F4 or to D4 so the world champion is
not going to wait idly by for nepo to
improve his position to the maximum but
yam continues to improve his position
and Black's clock continues to dwindle
he's down to 10 seconds and The Rook
from E4 is threatening to move to G4 and
so it does Black's Queen is not feeling
too comfortable F6 was actually the only
Escape Square for Black's Queen it was
almost trapped and now nepo could
continue to harass the queen and he does
just that 94 Queen F5 again the queen
with only one retreating square but
there is no way that I can see to trap
the queen right here the Knight can move
back to G3 nepo has a draw in his pocket
but obviously given the time situation
the draw is the last thing on his mind
Bishop comes out to G5 attacking The
Rook 97 Carlson with only five seconds
moving The Rook back to E8 and now the
move Knight G3 looks even more
terrifying the queen will have to move
back to G6 right into the path of a
potential discovered attack that can be
exerted by The Rook on G4 but I actually
don't see an effective Discovery the
bishop on G5 can move in a lot of
different directions But whichever way
it moves it's going to open up at least
one retreating Square for black screen
so I still can't see a way to trap the
black queen and maybe that is what nepo
was thinking about he himself is now
down to one minute Carlson intently
looking at the position making sure that
his Queen remains alive and somehow he
is actually maintained fundamental
soundness in his position the E5 Pawn is
still very well protected so nepo he's
got a nice looking position but Carlson
isn't going to lose by himself nepo has
to continue to find ways to put pressure
the Knight does drop back to G3 where is
nepo going to move his bishop or is he
going to support the bishop with the
move H4 he moves the Knight back to E4
and Carlson I would assume should be
very happy with the repetition of moves
here four seconds on the clock as he
slides the queen back up to F5 and nepo
39 seconds now he doesn't see anything
that he's truly liking he's down to 30
seconds now and in a Time scramble I
don't think black is really any worse
here nepo moves his Knight back to G3
and is he going to take the draw here is
he going to go for the repetition no
he's not no he's not he plays H4 he
supports the bishop and we're going to
get a good old-school barn burner here
we have a knight versus Bishop situation
the night
it moves back to E4 harassing Black's
Bishop the bishop moves back to D7 and
here comes magnus's Rook as it sinks its
teeth into F4 offering The Rook trade
and nepo could not have refused that
trade because he would have lost the
pawn that he moved to H4 a couple of
moves earlier and that pawn is already
on H5 White's Queen pouring into the
game with Queen F3 attacking the F4 pawn
and now posturing for a position moving
to G4 and Carlson repositioning his Rook
from EA to f8 lending a little bit more
support to the F4 Pawn But Here Comes
napo's Rook to E1 x-raying blacks Queen
three seconds for the world champion and
with just under three seconds he plays
Rook F5 nepo moves his King over to F1
he's training a discovery with one
second for Carlson he didn't make it he
did not make it he moved his Rook back
to fa but was not in time fantastic game
by Yanni punishi he just kept the
pressure going and if you like this
video make sure to click the link in the
playlist for more of these Blitz videos
thank you so much for watching
thank you